so I don't know I maybe I'm the only
person who's interested in this but the
the death of creativity in the United
States is very jarring to me that's true
in literature name three great novels
written since 1945 in English oh you
can't name 10 great Public Works
projects since 1945 oh not possible
something changed fundamentally since we
dropped that bomb and I don't think I'm
imagining it and by the way if you have
counter evidence to wreck my theories
please give it to me but I do think
something about the Godlike powers of
nuclear weapons convince people they are
God I think there may be some spiritual
force in effect there but whatever it is
that moment changed this country in the
entire West forever and diminished it
forever and I grew up defending the
bombing of Japan with the atomic weap go
oh you know we couldn't deal with an
invasion or whatever and now I'm
thinking in what way how insane was I to
defend dropping a nuclear bomb on people
if you find yourself defending that
you're a freak